Olha essa aqui. Você sabia que o seu
cérebro produz o próprio colesterol dele
completamente separado do resto do
corpo? Pois é, saiu agora um estudo da
Universidade do Texas mostrando que quem
tem HDL mais alto tem mais massa
cinzenta preservada e melhor memória
conforme envelhece. Mas tem um detalhe
importante. Outro estudo de 2025 mostrou
que o LDL elevado entre os 40 e 65 anos
aumenta o risco de Alzheimer. Mas calma,
não é qualquer LDL que é vilão. O
problema maior é o LDL oxidado, que vira
inflamatório e causa dano cerebral. O
LDL não oxidado, quando está controlado,
não faz esse estrago todo. O cérebro
precisa de colesterol para funcionar.
Ele usa isso para formar conexões entre
neurônios e manter tudo funcionando bem.
A questão é o equilíbrio e
principalmente evitar que esse LDL
oxide. Então se você quer proteger seu
cérebro, não é só olhar o número do
colesterol total no exame, tem que
avaliar HDL, LDL, idealmente pedir
marcadores de oxidação e seu cérebro
agradece. Yeah.